we were just out shooting you with
posing with scooby-doo unaware and the
fans going crazy yeah so tell me what's
up like your fans and supporting the
show for 13 years it's unreal I I feel I
feel so blessed I feel so similar and
that I also love this show you know I'm
I I guess I'm on a lot of the posters
and whatnot but I'm still just one actor
of the thousands of actors literally who
had been on the show in the last 13
years I haven't written a single word
I haven't produced an episode directing
episode so I'm part of this and I get to
moments like this I get to sit back and
look and be a fan which to me is really
cool because I you know we're going to
Canada tonight we're working 6 under
tomorrow and it's gonna be tough and I
go back to my job and I have a
responsibility but right now I get to be
a fan again so it's neat to be a fan
with other people it's like going to a
concert and going like you love Pearl
Jam too
how do you know so it's kind of cool to
be around the Kyocera tell me about the
scooby-doo episode
okay so scooby-doo we found out it was
whispered to us I want to say January or
2017 like hey we might do a scooby-doo
episode because some of the writers
really liked what we could do and they
can have access to the animators or were
like duh alright but didn't think it was
really legit and so then Jensen and
Misha and I went and recorded our audio
they wrote the script your quart of oil
and then was like okay well you'll see
it in 12 months I was like okay there
it's not gonna happen like I don't get
my hopes up that's part of being in the
business you know you got a thousand
auditions and you book one role but you
don't get your hopes up so you're like
okay if it happens cool cool I'm not
gonna put any weight on it I'm not gonna
lose any sleep because I don't be
heartbroken if I didn't happen so now as
I said here today I haven't seen it yet
but as I stand here today I'm pretty
stoked about getting to see it last
question chemistry with Jensen your
on-screen brother yeah he I think that
was pretty quick and pretty easy he he
and I have a lot in common
we were raised what we
that even as far as our football team
Dallas Cowboys you know so we had a lot
to talk about
and chat about and I think immediately
we were thrown into the fire together
you know 16-hour days 18-hour days
flying to do 18-hour publicity after
shooting a 12-hour day or whatever was
and so we realized really early on that
we had to be there for each other and it
was just natural it wasn't one of these
kind of fakey like hey the studio's
gonna buy y'all a dinner together so
y'all can just talk about something it
was just like hey well we're off at 6:00
want to go get a steak yeah so it was
just very it was super natural and
that's the cheesiest thing I've said all
my life